what does it mean for you to be here to
support your man tonight it means so
much I feel like I've been hearing about
this project since forever so to finally
see all of this come to fruition and
it's a beautiful thing this isn't gonna
make me change my mind mr. Platt time
did you just call me Pat I'm glad time
my family's from Korea in that time that
is not what I said so you can stop
waiting for an apology oh I'm waiting
for something but not for an apology
we're chatting with him at the junket he
revealed to us the us you love letters
I've always written letters write
letters at my latest Academy there's
just something about opening right the
letter and reading it date into time and
you know there's just something very uh
just simple you know as far as a little
bit more work I think they hate when you
just order flowers for somebody right
that's romantic for sure that's the most
romantic thing that you've done for him
personal I'll keep that to myself
[Music]